hello these are generated images
from a new model actually a new class of
model it's been around for a while
but uh for the first time this new class
of model
has been pushed to the point where the
images they produce
are not only look really nice and
look like something you kind of you've
come to expect
from the latest and greatest gan models
but also they are better in the standard
metrics we use to evaluate gans
specifically here
in the fid the the fresher inception
distance so the paper we're going to
talk about today is called diffusion
models beat gans on image synthesis
it's by portfolio dariwal and alex
nicole
of open ai i mean already in the title
they're pulling no
punches just be like this beats gans
okay so
in this paper they're mainly talking
about
improvements to this new class of models
which they call
diffusion models now i would like to
dive a bit more into what diffusion
models are instead of just telling you
what the improvements of this paper are
because i think most people haven't come
in contact
with these types of models yet so
they thoroughly reference another paper
which is called improved denoising
diffusion probabilistic
models by themselves and
in this paper they go they more
develop these new models than in the
other paper this
the paper here as you can see it's just
like three months younger than the other
paper so
this is really close i think this paper
is more insightful into what these
models are that being said
you know by the name improved right here
you can also see
that this is not kind of the seminal
paper of
these types of models so if you're
interested in that you have to go eve
back
even further however we're going to look
at this
and we're going to look at the new paper
and see what are
all the things that lead to this new
class of models being better than gans
specifically we're going to talk about
ddpms
uh denoising diffusion probabilistic
models
and they're a bit they're a bit like a
variational autoencoder
like a little bit um yeah
but we'll go through that all right so
if if you feel that this was helpful
uh please do share it out it's been it's
been a pleasure
uh bringing this to a lot of people and
if you do it will just be more people
will have more fun
right so they say that denoising
diffusion probabilistic models
ddpms are a class of generative models
which have recently been shown to
produce excellent samples
okay and we show that with a few simple
modifications
ddpms can also achieve competitive log
likelihoods
while maintaining high sample quality so
in this
paper they take these models these ddpm
models
and they say look we can push those
to to push their their log likelihood
so there are a number of metrics that
generative models track it's not as easy
as
kind of the validation set accuracy in a
classifier
log likelihood is one of the metrics
that
these models track and here they say
well we can get competitive log
likelihood while maintaining high sample
quality which is a nice way of saying we
don't beat gans yet
right in the next paper then you know
the one i showed you before they
actually do beat gans on the
standard metrics and also the samples
look quite
quite impressive so ddpms
have been around before but they go into
a quick overview right here which is
uh what i think is quite appropriate
for us to dive in so
the the philosophy here or the whole
the whole purpose behind um behind this
is they say let's imagine
i have an image right i have an image
of i don't know my house right here i
have an image of a house
and i define a process what they call a
forward
noising process and this forward noising
process
takes the image and it just adds a
little bit of noise to it like epsilon
noise that's sampled from some standard
distribution like a gaussian
okay so you just sample a bit of noise
and
you just add it to that image so you
have the same house
but there's there'll be a bit of noise
on it okay
and then you do it again okay so
you sample another bit of noise and
sorry this
comes from this distribution and you do
it again
and as you do this over many steps
and here they they actually they notice
that the previous authors were using a
thousand steps
and if they just increase that to 4 000
steps
it like the log likelihoods go better in
any case
you do this for many steps um thousands
of steps in
this first instance you do this
what are you going to end up with well
the argument here is that if you do this
for so many times
for so long over so many steps
you're going to end up with random noise
itself right
so this is ish ish according to
some kind of normal distribution okay
you just assume
right and you can actually prove this
that if you do enough step like if you
do infinitely many steps
and um it goes actually towards
just noise so whenever you're done with
this there is
like no more information about the
original image than actually sampling
from this distribution right here
so you've successfully defined a process
that takes you
from the image space right this here is
from the data space
that takes you from the data space to a
known distribution
which is the normal distribution now
here is the the kind of the logic
if we could invert this
like if we just somehow could invert
this mapping
right if we can have a process that
knows
if i give you an image with some noise
can you tell me what image that
came from right um
is is that doable right it's not it's
not
it's it's thinkable right if i give you
like this image
with some specks of noise on it and i
ask you
could you please give me like i tell you
i pro like i i'm the oracle i tell you
look i've taken some image right
that already had a bit of noise on it
but but i've added more
like i've taken an image i've added some
noise what
was the original image that
i i don't tell you what the noise is
right i just tell you the noise comes
from
whatever a normal distribution i've
added it what was the original image now
you
looking at this image you'll see uh you
know this
could be a house um so
not quite sure but you know this might
be something like this might be the
original image
and this here i'm not really sure about
if this is noise
so you're gonna sort of revert that
process a little bit right
knowing that this is how the image came
to be
you as a human if i told you you
could approximately reverse that process
that of course requires you to know
something about these images right
that like it requires you to know what a
house looks like and when you see
something like this that
well you know probably um because i
don't tell you which ones are the noise
and which ones aren't
so that's the trick right if i just told
you well all the orange stuff
is noise right but you you just see you
just see this all in mono color
but you know kind of okay so this here
looks like it's
from the image itself but then this here
is just kind of a speck
and that just kind of might just be
noise maybe not
right but then this here i'm pretty sure
it's just noise
and not part of the original image so
you could do that and the question is
can we learn
a function that does this reverse
process if we can do so
right if we can learn a function
function
of course that's going to be some kind
of neural network-ish thing
we can learn a function where i give you
an image with noise
and i tell you by the way so this is
maybe
time step zero here this is t
equals zero t equals one t
equals two and so on well you can't see
that
um if i tell you okay here is an image
um this happened at t equals 50
can you give me the t equals 49
image that that this came from
all right and this is the whole
principle
we're going to we can generate training
data
for this neural network very easily
because we just take data
and we run them uh through the noise
process forward
right then we have plenty of training
data for every step
of this pipeline right in fact we don't
train a
i we don't train a different uh five
function for every
step as you can see the five function
simply takes the time
or can take the time as an input it's
certainly
possible otherwise or it's possible to
not tell it at all
right then you it has no clue
um so yeah
if you do if you do this you can
generate training data and then the idea
is you can just
run this process in reverse and
arrive at the original sample and even
more
because this here is actually
the normal distribution you can now
sample random noise from that normal
distribution right
you can feed it to this process and this
process
um who has learned to map the data
distribution to the normal distribution
and can reverse that process will give
you some sort of
data distribution sample for your
input that you sampled from the normal
distribution
all right this is the idea and
it's it's quite tricky to get this to
work
as you can imagine um but
let's not forget that gans
also have been quite tricky to get to
work it's just
maybe there has been a bit more work
going into gans
right so formally this goes as follows
we define this forward noising process
right by
we sample this from the data
distribution we sample x
zero from the data distribution we
define
this forward noising process q okay
which produces x1 through xt so capital
t
as the the end here um and
we by adding gaussian noise
at time t with some variants okay so
you can have you can have uh it's zero
mean gaussian noise
uh i believe maybe
yeah it's well you you scale but
you define this variance schedule right
here
uh that's also your choice right you
choose
how you what kind of noise you want to
add
but ultimately you take
ultimately the the distribution
of the things you produce via that
noising process
given that you start at the date to
sample x
zero you simply define as this product
of distributions
so you start with this just means you
start with x
zero and then you go from x zero to x
one and then you go from x one to x2
and so on okay and each of these steps
is an independent
application of noise
as you can see here this is one of those
steps so what you're saying
is that the distribution of the next
sample
right here is going to be a normal
distribution that's going to be centered
at this thing right here and its
variance
is this thing right here so you can see
that
the assumption here is you use noise
that has a diagonal covariance matrix
okay this is i guess it's reasonable
um it certainly makes computing things
easier
right the other thing here is that you
can see
this gaussian is centered at the last
sample but
down scaled by this factor right here
and i think like this is a choice again
by the modelers but
i think this is also due to the fact
that makes computation
easier because i guess if you don't have
this
then um you know you start somewhere and
you add noise and
you sample something you add noise you
sample something maybe
e this would grow indefinitely and you
sort of need to rescale things
such that you can make this statement
right here
given sufficiently large t and a
well-behaved schedule of beta
the latent xt so the very last step
is nearly an isotropic gaussian
distribution
okay that's the entire point
so if you do it like this which is a
choice
but if you do it like this then at the
end if you do enough steps
uh infinitely many steps then you end up
at an isotropic gaussian distribution
thus if we know the exact reverse
distribution
we can sample from the gaussian and run
the process in reverse
to get a sample from the data
distribution
then now they say however since the
reverse distribution depends on the
entire data distribution
we approximate it using a neural network
as follows
so this statement is can be a bit weird
um in in first instance the
this depends on the entire data
distribution
right because it's it's very close
to this thing right here and this thing
right here
uh depends on nothing right this you
just define you just say i'm gonna add
random noise to something and that's my
next distribution
it only depends on the the input image
right here
the the way to see it that this depend
the reverse depends on the entire data
distribution is exactly what i said
before
if i give you the ha if like if i give
you this picture
i'm not going to actually tell you right
where the noise is
so i give you this picture
and i i tell you this is uh this is a
drawing
from a very small child because that's
my drawing level
um and i've just added a bunch of noise
to it
could you tell me what the original
drawing was
right this is very different from me
saying
um here is a drawing from a small child
please
add noise to it that's easy i just did
this right i'm i was just
called i just did it but if i tell you
what was the original image
you have to take into account the entire
you know world like you know about
how small children's draw what kind of
motives they usually
draw and so on and that's how you are
able to come up
by saying well it was probably that like
it was probably something
like this uh so this needs
this needs your knowledge of the entire
data distribution
that's why they say right here okay so
they say well we can't
we like we we can't just
have the entire data distribution
otherwise you know we wouldn't even
have the problem in the first place so
what we can do
is we can approximate one of these steps
using a neural network
okay so the we have a neural network
that takes as an input
as i said it takes as an input uh the
noise version of the image and
it gives you as an output it's a bit
like this is it gives you i told you
give me the image that this came from in
this case what they want is
give me a distribution over images
where that could have come from right
and again they say this
they they model this as a gaussian right
here
and the neural network will produce the
mean and the covariance matrix
given the image so the neural network is
supposed to look at the image
and decide okay what's the gaussian
distribution
of images where that probably came from
and this is a strong assumption right
uh the fact for example that you know
this is a gaussian distribution
like this is this is adequately modeled
as a gaussian distribution
it's a strong assumption that you can
only make
because you make these very small steps
because nothing i mean nothing stops you
from actually doing this in one step
right nothing stops you from from or
taking you know the data distribution
just adding
like a wild bonds of noise because then
you're also approximately
normal normally distributed uh maybe not
i don't know you maybe end up at some
other distribution
but i mean certainly um
if you like you can do the reverse also
you can train a neural network to do it
in one step
uh in fact that's a little bit what gans
do
right but if you want to do this in this
sort of
manner where you model all the
distributions notice this is a very
different language than gans
here it's all it's all kind of in the
distributional semantics
if you want to do this and you want to
say well i modeled the reverse as a
normal distribution
this is just not true if you took
large enough steps right but if you take
very tiny steps
you can you can adequately make sort of
the argument that the normal
distribution is
kind of okay for this to work
and of course it makes life easier after
that
so they need the tiny steps because
in the tiny steps they're able to sort
of the modeling assumptions
hold also i guess it works better
and and then you can define
a the the loss function right here so
they say the combination of q and p
is a variational auto encoder and we can
write the variational lower bound as
follows
so i have i'm not sure if i have ever
gone over variational auto encoders
but they it's very much
it's very similar to here what you can
do
is you can define this variational lower
bound
um which essentially boils down to
saying
i would like the distribution that
i want a model and the the thing i
actually output
to be close together right so this is
the
reverse process that my neural network
does
and this is the thing that i actually
would like to model
okay and we're going to this is the the
thing that
needs the entire data distribution we're
going to look at that in just
a second um
so
yeah there are some other terms here but
you can you can get around
that uh and the last term right here
like the last term you just assume
that's kind of a
a gaussian so really it comes down to
does the distribution that your neural
network outputs
match what you what it actually is
and here you can see the sort of proxy
for
well this needs the whole data
distribution is
the following if i
if i tell you that this is the process
by which i derive the data
right and i ask you what is the reverse
distribution of one of these steps
you can't possibly compute that right
accurately because you don't know the
data distribution however what you can
do is
for this particular sample you can
compute it
if i tell you that you know this is the
process by which i derived it
and also if i actually give you x0
right here if i give you that then you
can do
you can do um
you can calculate and that's what they
show here you can actually calculate
this distribution you can say what is
the actual distribution
i'd like to model and that's going to be
a normal distribution it would just it
makes sense right
uh to in this case like if this
is if this is the forward process
um and i give you x0
if you already know the result you can
calculate the distribution so that's
what they derive right here
and that is dependent of course on your
noise scale
um which is
like all over the place in this in these
formulas
but you can calculate that and this is a
gaussian
and they model the output output of the
neural network as a gaussian
so these kl divergences just they become
really easy to calculate
and then you have a loss function
so now they say how do we how do we
actually train this thing in practice
because it turned out in the last papers
that
this thing right here the actual
variational lower bound
isn't too effective
um
i think that's what they're saying uh
so yeah
what the um what the authors here say
is they go back to previous paper they
say
the previous paper found that
modeling the noise here is the
best way to do it so the question is
how exactly what exactly does the neural
network do
like the neural network could do many
things
it it could actually just predict
this mean parameter which we've talked
about
right the neural network could simply i
give you an image and you tell me
what's the most probable image where it
comes from or sort of the mean
and also give me the covariance but also
what it what you could do is you could
just model the noise that's a different
thing
you could model the noise
and that's equivalent from a
computational perspective right or from
a conceptual perspective
um if i give you again this image
you can either tell me where it came
from
or equivalently you can tell me what's
the noise that i've added
right and you tell me what this you've
probably added this noise
it's a this is a both the same
from an information perspective however
the authors previously noted that the
modeling the noise
is better uh just from a neural network
training
standpoint in fact they make a point
here
to define a new loss function that
simply
estimates that simply says well
the noise that i output from the neural
network
should approximately match the actual
noise that i've added
right because i know what noise i
sampled in my forward noising process
and that works better however
these authors here say okay
this does not tell you anything about
the covariance because that
only tells you something about the mean
and the old authors found
that we don't actually need the
covariance we just
we fix it and that works a lot better or
equally well to actually learning it
and the authors here say maybe
they've you know missed something maybe
they've missed the opportunity
to learn the covariance so this was a
little bit of a rant
but to repeat we define
this noising process and then we try to
learn a neural network that reverts that
noising process
in order to do so we
train a neural network to reverse each
of the little steps that we do
right here and the way we do it
is the neural network will predict the
distribution of the predecessor
so given a noise image the neural
network will output
the distribution modeled as a normal
distribution
over where that noisy image probably
came from
and it the previous authors have said
well there are two things to model there
is the mean
and the covariance and we find
first of all if we just fix the
covariance that's enough
right we fix the the covariance matrix
to the
noise scale that we know we applied
and good enough um we don't actually
need to model the the true covariance
matrix
just from an empirical standpoint and
then when we model the mean
um we don't model the mean directly we
actually model the noise
and which is equivalent but it works
better from a neural network standpoint
the authors now say maybe you've missed
an opportunity
learning that covariance matrix because
it's
one thing to say this is probably a
gaussian
right it's another thing to say this is
probably a gaussian with completely
isotropic
covariance matrix uh you would expect
the second one
is easier but also it's more wrong so
that's what we're that's what we go
about here
so they say can we improve the log
likelihood right here
and the first topic they go into is
learning this covariance
matrix and what they discover i want to
say
is that if you fix the covariance matrix
right here you have to know what scale
to fix it at
which is dependent on the noise that you
applied in the forward process
right so you applied some noise and you
can calculate
uh what the average
covariance of the reverse step should be
at that particular time step
and in fact you can derive an upper and
the lower bound
so if beta here is their schedule for
noise
then these are the two bounds so this
this is the actual beta you used in that
step the noise
scale and this is sort of an accumulated
noise scale up until that step
these are the two bounds in which uh
in which the noise can be right the
noise level
or the covariance and the previous
author said well
we can use either one of them it's
actually fine it doesn't matter
and these authors say okay look at this
right here this is the ratio
between the two so the ratio between the
upper and the lower bound
as a function of the diffusion step now
especially if you go to a large amount
of step size you see this immediately
clamps at one right so there is like
almost
no difference between the upper and the
lower bound
which is probably why the other authors
estimated it didn't matter now these
authors go further and they say
well if you just try to learn
like a number neural networks are kind
of bad at regression right
so if you tell neural network learn me
any number
on the number string whatever you call
that in english
um if there are me any number like
here's one here's two
here's three like here's 500
any number whatsoever but however
uh the only actual right answers are
going to be a tiny tiny sliver
between like uh like the ratio between
them is going to be a tiny tiny sliver
somewhere in in like three orders of
magnitude down
the neural network's going to have
trouble hitting these correctly
so the way they do it is they
reparameterize
the uh the how they predict the
covariance matrix
in fact what they come up with is they
simply
learn an interpolation parameter
v right here to interpolate between the
upper and the lower bound
and that turns out to be quite a good
decision because now the neural network
can predict
a number v for each dimension which is
between zero and one
right and um that's neural networks can
predict stuff between zero and one
they're pretty good at it
and the whole rest the whole scale issue
will be
taken care of by um interpolating
between the two valid bounds
so this this is one thing they're able
to learn the covariance matrix now
and that boosts them um a bit
and then they also look at the noising
process right here
and they say well if you look at this
and this is something i find a bit shady
they say if you look at this and this
top
row is what is currently done with the
noise
schedule that is usually defined
it's just kind of noisy a bit too much
right like from
here on out there's just
noise right could we not schedule this
a little bit such that the drop-off is
more gradual
that might help a lot and so they come
up with a new schedule
that does this now this seems very
subjective right
you know this is you as a human looking
at it they they do some experiments here
where they say um we measure
the inception distance as we just leave
away
a fraction of the reverse diffusion
process so they they wonder
how many of these steps can we just
leave away and still end up with
something that's fine like can we can we
just skip the first step of the reverse
process and start here can we skip five
steps and start here
it turns out in the linear schedule
you're just able to skip a lot more
steps
which gives you an indication that those
steps weren't really helpful
and it'd probably be better that you
define a schedule
where all of the steps are helpful
so that's what they what they come up
with you can see the linear
schedule right here is dumping pretty
fast like it goes down pretty fast
well their new cosine schedule uh is
much much slower like this these are now
actual practical considerations that are
just done by
kind of looking evaluating a bit
empirically
and then going and saying well can't we
do something
better now there's something better they
admit that themselves isn't by no means
the best
thing you can do it's just something
better like ultimately you would want
the same
step in the noising process probably to
contribute equally
to the quality of the entire system you
know but that's what they do
the last thing is very similar they say
we reduce the gradient noise
so they observe if they use
um they have now two loss functions
right they have the loss the original
loss function
where you simply look at the l2 distance
between the noise and the predicted
noise like no variation a lower bound
yadda
kl divergence who needs that crap right
that's what they call the simple
objective now
the simple objective doesn't contain the
covariance so what they would like to do
is they would like to go back to the
variational objective and that's the
blue line here i know
you can't really read it but that's the
blue line here and you can see
not only is it pretty noisy it's also
well
okay i guess it's like it's pretty noisy
the loss curve
if they mix the variational objective
together with the simple objective they
get a better loss curve you see that
right here
this this is this hybrid loss it's the
orange loss
it it's still noisy
they are new laws which they call
re-sampled loss
um that's again the variation lower
bound loss
but sampled in a different way
is the green line which is much much
smoother
and also lower
and that comes from this fact right here
if
you look at um
the sorry
not from this right here where is it
okay so they what they say is
if you look at the process like this
noise
process here and you look at where the
actual
loss comes from where does the majority
of the loss contribution come from
they notice that the majority of the
loss contribution comes
from the first steps so there's a real
imbalance
of how much these individual steps in
the noising process
uh differ from like contribute to
the overall loss and they say well
if you know if we just add all of them
up
equally right because what do you need
to do to train
these neural networks you need to start
off with a clean image
then sample some step like some step you
say okay i'm gonna now train the
t equals uh 205
network right so you add noise 205 times
you can do this in one go by the way
but essentially you add noise 205 times
you get here right you add noise once
more
to here and now you have your you have
your training sample
right here uh you can calculate the the
um
the distribution you want to match by
also including
this one as we discussed and you're good
right
so this is one training sample the next
training sample is you select a
different t
and you produce another training sample
and so on now
if the first few steps are much more
important than you know the step at
t equals 5 000 um and you're just
sampling t
uniform you will end up with you know
a correct on probably unbiased estimate
of your laws oh sorry of your loss
however it will be super duper noisy
so they're saying can't we just focus a
bit on
where are the loss actually occurs
so they devise a scheme
to do important sampling okay
notice that the different terms of
of the variational around have greatly
different
magnitudes and figure two where's which
one's figure
oh figure two figure two ah there we go
that was the plot uh so here is the step
in the noising process
and here is the lost term magnitude and
you can see that the
the first few steps they have a really
like a larger loss this is a log scale
right on the left
than the last ones so
they devise an important sampling scheme
to counter
that this is not specific right to
this particular technique you can use
this anywhere
where different samples have very
different contributions
to loss you can choose to focus on the
ones
where the loss is high and
that will not give you that will give
you a biased estimate of
your loss however it might decrease your
variance by quite a bit
and that's what they they end up with
they um in this paper they end up with
something that's competitive but not
better than the best gans
however it already it already looks
pretty good
they also investigate model size but i
don't wanna
go into this i actually wanna jump
quickly into this
next paper
where they improve again on their models
to make them actually better than gans
and the improvements right here
are much more i don't know i want to say
boring
because like okay architecture
improvements
so we're going through the same process
that we've gone through
with gans where it's like well here's a
tweak here's a tweak here is an
architecture a better architecture
here's kind of a better
loss function regularize or whatnot and
it's quite conceivable right
that uh this these models here come to
the level of gans now
whether they are actually you know
better than gans
i like i think this is remains to be
seen
because you know it also depends quite a
bit on how much compute you put into
this and then you also have to see that
here
you have to you want when you want to
sample
a sample you have to input the sample
and then do this denoising process a
bunch of times like thousands of times
until you end up with the data sample
now they do have a
kind of a trick going into another model
class
where uh you only
have to have they say 25 of these steps
uh so it's pretty cool but still like
that's 25
forward passes through this neural
network that predicts
the denoising where again
is just like you sample once the latent
you sh
you ship it through the gan and you end
up
with a you
end up with a sample and i'm actually
wondering
if gans could take some sort of lesson
from here we'll we'll look at this after
we look at this right here
which is what i think is the kind of
cool improvement that they do in the new
paper which is where they say
classifier guidance so
um they say if you use gans for
conditional image synthesis
so if you if you conditionally
if you use again to create images that
are of like a particular class
conditioned on a class label they make
heavy use of class label
okay so they say
it makes sense to explore different ways
to condition
diffusion models on class labels we
already incorporate class information
into normalization layers so you have
different normalization layers for
different
classes here we explore a different
approach exploiting a classifier to
improve a diffusion
generator okay um
they say the kind of a previous work
two previous show one way to achieve
this we're in a pre-trained diffusion
model can be conditioned using the
gradients of a classifier in particular
we can train a classifier and on noisy
images
and then use the gradients to guide the
diffusion sampling process towards an
arbitrary class label in this section we
first review two ways of deriving
conditional sampling processes we then
describe
how we use such classifiers in practice
to improve
sample quality so
the idea here is that if you have class
labels together with your data set
you can train a classifier on not only
the data set but also noisy samples of
that data set right
and then you can use that classifier in
order
to guide the process right
so this is what we're dealing with right
here
uh they say well instead of simply
reverting the process which would be
this part right here
like instead of simply reverting the
noise process
if i tell you what label
that image is from like what class that
image is from
can you do a better job right so if i in
our original
example if i tell you if i give you a
noisy picture of a house
and i tell you well by the way this is a
house
you're much more able to tell me what
the original image was or
alternatively what the noise is that
i've added to the image
so if you write this as a
as a distribution as we did so far
you can say if you you want to predict
the
previous image from the next image and
the class label
and you can pull this apart into these
two
components which is the old
component like how likely is the
previous image given the noisy version
times
the what they i think they call this
this the prior right
um yeah they call this
prior you can see that if you just like
kind of ship
this out it just um it just
swaps well i don't know how to explain
this properly
but i mean this is this is just
probability
manipulation so
if you you have a probability
product between whatever we had before
and
how likely is that is the class label
under this so this is sort of
you want an image that makes sense given
the noisy image but you also want
you want an image that's that mac that
has a high
probability of being of the class that
you want to produce
and of course this is exactly a
classifier on the right
which you can use so since
we since our model
of so the question is what are these two
things
and can we sort of derive an easy form
how we can work with this
so the first thing we've already seen
and we model this as a normal
distribution
and if we know the mean and covariance
of that thing
the the log is simply
this form so you should recognize this
as being just the form of the normal
distribution
this here is the normalization constant
if you work in log space
that is added and it is a constant
so if you're just interested in
minimizing a function
you might as well leave it away
the second part is a bit more tricky
but you can say well this distribution
right here
i can do a taylor expansion around the
predicted mean right then a first order
taylor expansion
which becomes this so this is it's just
kind of a
a vector form of the taylor expansion if
you've never seen it
so this is um this is f
of x 0 right here and this
is the this is f of x one this is the
derivative
um at the point
x zero how do you say it is the
derivative according to x at x zero
times x minus x0
right here it's the same thing okay so
what you end up with
um is this form right here
and if you calculate this through
what you end up with is the entire
distribution so the product of the two
things
in log space looks like this
and therefore um
therefore the distribution
that you're looking at is a distribution
you're saying
here somewhere is the image that is the
noisy version
you ask your two models you ask your
first model
well what's what's an image or
where does this likely come from and
that model tells you well it's probably
from here
and the the covariance is like
so like i i think that's where it it
came from when it was noised
and the other model simply shifts that
towards it says well but
if you shift it a bit like this
and it actually comes from here then
it's much more likely
under the classifier right that's what
you have
you have the predicted mean right here
that says where does it probably come
from given that i've had a noise and
this part right here
says so the g is the gradient
of the classifier with respect to the
input
this says well but if i shift it like
this a little bit it becomes much more
likely under the class
and given that you've already told me
what the class label is
right i'm just going to choose um i'm
going to choose to shift
over here so this is what the classifier
buys you the classifier
will tell you without the classifier i
think it comes from here
but now that i know it comes from this
class i can refine
my belief of where it came from and
that's how you become more accurate
like if this is really the class it came
from you're going to be more accurate
right given that the assumptions of the
taylor
expansion hold now here
as you can see we're really kind of
getting close to the land of the gans
okay now um if as soon as you have
something
like this where you derive the gradient
of a model
right uh of a classifier model with
respect
to its input and you use that gradient
to sort of guide your search
that is it's it's very close to again
it's very close to models that
do score matching actually this
very bad at explaining score matching
but it is exactly
sort of this you use the gradient of the
log probability
in order to model a distribution and i
wonder
if gans can't sort of take a bit of a
lesson from here like i wonder
what happens if you don't have a gan
that just goes from
noise to data but again like
like here you have like little gans uh
or the discriminators at intermediate
steps right that do their discrimination
you can generate
training data pretty easily again by
doing this
reverse noising process you can generate
training data
and you just have like little
discriminators that discriminate between
true data that was actually noised and
data that you just produced and by you
just produced
i don't know what i'm just coming up
with this right now this is not a
prepared thing by the way
um you could probably use your existing
model
to somehow forward propagate and then
you noise whatever that is right
and then you have generated data and
true data in all their noisy fashion
and you can do discriminator at each
level
i'm not sure maybe it works maybe it
won't
um i'm i'm just saying maybe there's a
way to get sort of the best out of both
worlds
because this this here uh like if this
weren't a class label but
kind of a label of true and fake data
this would very much look like again
and maybe we don't need all of this
distribution
distribution distribution um
i i guess it's a forever war between
people who do
formally corrector things and people
um who just throw everything out that
doesn't contribute to the end quality
in any case they also go into this
ddim models which are a different class
of models
very close here but they do they
they say to this and we use a score
based conditioning trick
uh adapted from these other papers which
leverages the connection between
diffusion models and score matching so
there is an actual
formal connection and you can use that
to kind of actually what i said right
now get rid of
the noise in the system
and directly uh sort of
directly predict the predecessors
and that will still end up at a formally
correct thing
and that allows you i think with this
trick they don't have to sample as much
or they they only use 25 reverse steps
instead of 4 000
which is important right
and the last thing they discover if they
discover like a hyper parameter like if
you scale
classifier gradients like this you have
to observe that
the classifier gradients are in log
scale so
technically uh the way multiplication
behaves with a log
is it becomes an exponent right here and
that simply means that this distribution
uh also you know the normalization that
distribution is going to be more or less
peaky
defined depending on that hyper
parameter
and they notice that you can make it
sort of more peaky
and then the sample quality becomes
higher
right i think they a issue that the
variational autoencoders had for a long
time is that they were sort of blurry
and so on
and you know this is this is a little
bit i think
how that might be fixed though this is
you know the classifier gradients
so you want to make the classifier
gradients more peaky
which means that you get a stronger
signal for from them
um which
apparently results in better things
so here all the results you see whenever
they say
adm that's their model they have
several variations namely this dash
g here is the classifier guided version
and whenever they say 25 steps that is
the version
without the noise with the trick
connection to score matching
yep so you can see in sort of the
fid scores they do beat
a big gan on these tasks
yeah maybe the you know the gans will
one up taking some tricks from here
or maybe it's quite possible that these
models will
go beyond gans because we've poured
a lot of effort into gans and not so
much yet
into these models into
the denoising models and you know the
samples look pretty good so the left is
began
and the middle here it's a bit small but
the middle here is
is their model and i have actually
like i've gone through this entire
imagenet class
i've looked at every single image to try
to find these images and i can i can
tell you that
the images are not in the training
or the validation data set uh here are
these are images from
the actual data set they're pretty close
but still
i always fear a little bit that you know
at some point a model is just going to
learn to copy the data
all right so that was it i know this
video is already too long if you're
still here
thank you i hope you've enjoyed this
and i'll see you next time bye-bye